trash et becky nos en russie à quelques
kilomètres de la frontière ukrainienne
la guerre fait partie du paysage ces
charges et un nom soviétique servent de
rappel des conflits passés aujourd'hui
les habitants pourraient être en
première ligne si une guerre éclatait
mais pour la plupart il ne se passera
rien
un sentiment partagé par certains
ukrainiens notamment à odessa dans le
sud
en revanche d'autres se disent très
inquiets pour eux la paix ne tient qu'à
un fil
ces gâteaux plus de cent mille soldats
russes ont rassemblé à la frontière
ukrainienne la russie dément tout projet
d'invasion mais moscou s'estiment
menacés par l'entrée de l'ukraine au
sein de l'otan de leur côté les
occidentaux continuent de mettre la
pression sur la russie pour une
désescalade